people always say what do you want your
legacy to be I want to be known as one
of the greats
meet Shaquille O'Neal what's up baby my
mama always used to say something
special about that one take you back 13
years old six nine it was a guy who says
you're six nine you can't dump I give
him the beat down of his life at that
point I was dreaming about being a
rapper I was dreaming about being a
basketball player I was just dreaming
about being rich I think what carries
him is support that he always got from
family my father always told me I'm
Gonna Make You better than I was
my dad will always tell us y'all might
hate my ways but you love my results his
words if you listen to me I make you one
of the best basketball players ever
when I won the championship my father
says you know how we roll brother go get
another one yes sir
when he wants to take over a game with
his strength and athleticism there's
nothing you can do legitimately one of
the best Senators that the NBA had ever
seen he was like 373 pounds he's a big
guy because of my size they had to get
super physical but my superpowers get
mad when I get mad it's over
when you're at the top little chinks in
your armor that are underneath everybody
just to look up at those for longer that
was under the most pressure I'm still
dealing with it
I like making people
One mission in life now to just brighten
up people's day he chooses to just be
fun
let you kill be Shaquille and the magic
will come stop just shoot the money
brother
I always take advantage of opportunities
I want to make so much money on the side
his message to me was whatever you got
to do with your Brands make sure it's
your voice like Frederick mutry over
here I really am the man is that an
example the other brand yourself beyond
the game you can't open your eyes will
not see him
you want to follow this quizzing his son
on a great big man of the game
hopefully Shaquille O'Neal's name would
be in the answer
who going harder than me
[Music]